let's just jump straight into the phones
to start taking some calls from these
folks let's start with Jeff in Knoxville
hey Jeff welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave hey Rachel huge fan how y'all
doing good Madison your question for
Rachel about kids and money yeah hey you
know what I'm a former UT grad go Vols
evolved yeah and Rachel you probably
don't remember me but we had a math
class together i sat in the very back
and honestly I tried to flirt with you
once oh that's the water into the bridge
I married LuAnn Rogers do you remember
her yeah you guys had some classes
together she had short brown hair really
stocky anyway let me get to my question
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm supposed to get
to my question
so Rachel my wife and I I'm sorry I'm
emotional because your book has meant so
much to us smart money smart kids and
what my question is we're trying to
understand the tripping funds principle
and and I guess my question is what age
do you stop the DFP and does it drift
until they're a certain age or do you
eventually turn the faucet off
completely
you